This first answer is simply false.
Both objects are translated by some
amount from the origin.
The second answer is true.
If you scale by the same scaling matrix,
the objects are the same size.
They may be in different positions, but
they'll have the same dimensions.
The objects is not in the same position.
If you scale up by a million, then move a
foot, you've moved a foot for case A.
If you move a foot, then scale it up by a
million, its origin will essentially move
a million feet, for case B.
This next one could be true or false.
It depends on the scale factor.
If the object is growing larger, then
it's true, B would move farther than A.
If the object is shrinking, A would move
farther than B.